savez vous que ce sont des moines qui
ont raconté les aventures de goupil à
l'origine il s'agissait de contes et de
coësmes ans n'atteint que pierre de
saint cloud traduisit en langage
populaire le roman si le roman de renart
montre des personnages aux prises avec
la lutte pour la vie si l'état fidèle
reflet des coutumes de la fin du xiième
siècle il n'en reste pas moins avant
tout un divertissement mais chut silence
on tourne
[Musique]
nous allons vous conter l'histoire des
aventures des aventures nous allons vous
conter l'histoire les aventures de
là
or dans run à ce jour là
[Musique]
le
le son est
est ce
[Musique]
que t'arrive-t-il tu me semble en bien
mauvais points n'aurais tu pas de génie
non justement
mais elle n'en est même pas envie que me
chante tu là d'un versant venez donc
préparé pour renard une de ces
brochettes de rognons dont vous avez le
secret voici trois beaux jambon que vous
ne devriez pas exposer ainsi si l'un de
vos voisins les voiliers l'embrassa par
un conseil d'état chez les sans perdre
un instant et aller crier partout quand
vous les a volés
bon je ne suis pas inquiet sur leur sort
sinon vous en demandez vous refuseriez
absolument
[Musique]
ans
à bientôt
vos brochettes était excellent
[Musique]
une
où
[Musique]
mon 3 au vert mais j'en doute mais cher
jambes disparu au volant au secours aux
voleurs qu'avez-vous à crier ainsi au au
nord
mais jean baud on me les a pris bravo je
vois que vous suivez mes conseils il
faut aller aussi le criaient dans le
village que vos voisins le sache bien
mais au nord c'est la vérité on m'a volé
mes joies vos dit toujours on dit
toujours mais enfin puisque je vous
attends